Thank You Constance thank you Tom thank
you very much I sound great when they
talk about me
so bye my sincere thanks to the
governors for this this incredible honor
I'm very very grateful and I promise I
won't let it go to my head
because I think I'm pretty much the same
you know a small town
goofy gal that I always was it's it's so
funny because I was just talking about
this with the the driver in the
motorcade on the way over here
it's funny so so one day several months
ago I was shocked to get a flurry of
texts telling me that I needed to call
John Bailey immediately so I got a
little worried that that perhaps I had
committed some Academy crime but to find
out that it was like this always was
really really wonderful I love being
part of our industry and I have so much
passion for acting it's my joy in life
and I've also been passionate about
empowering women as you heard and girls
in part by seeking roles that I think
might resonate with them in some way in
fact I have only played role models what
all right so I wasn't a movie called
earth girls are easy this was very early
on I think we put that one title aside
you can take me seriously the film that
actually changed my life was Thelma and
Louise
it it really did and it made me realize
in a very powerful way how few
opportunities we give women to come out
of a movie
feeling excited and empowered by the
female characters and this led me to
have a very profound interest in the way
girls and women are depicted in the
world so years later when my daughter
Alizee was a toddler that spidey-sense
led me to notice that there should be
far more male characters and female
characters in media made for young kids
really I thought surely by now we should
be showing kids that boys and girls
share the sandbox equally but when I
started talking to content creators
about it to a person they said oh no no
no that's been fixed and they felt a
responsibility they were serious they
felt a responsibility to do right by
girls and they thought they were so how
could that be how could the people
creating content not be aware of how
bereft of female presence their
creations were so now I realized I
needed the data and it turns out that
the message that we are sending is that
men and boys are far more valuable to us
than women and girls there's just one
small example if you look at the
occupations of characters in film 81
percent of the characters with jobs are
male and the number of women in top
professions are profoundly
underrepresented even compared to the
low real life stats so in other words
however abysmal the numbers are in real
life it's far worse in fiction
where you make it up can be anything you
want and we make it worse than the
crappy reality
people cat characterized us Hollywood
types as bleeding-heart liberals LGBTQ
and diversity champions and all that
hardly if we were supposed to be a bunch
of gender-fluid intersectional feminist
then by God let's do it up right
let's live up to our label live up to
our stereotype do we really want to
stand by the idea that it's fine for
female characters to be one-dimensional
narrowly stereotyped hyper sexualized or
simply not there at all so this is why I
choke us I chose to focus on what kids
see first it's just common sense don't
create a problem that you have to try to
solve later on think about how
dramatically different our world would
be if we hadn't all grown up with these
unconscious biases and I also want to be
clear I'm not talking about making the
lead character a female don't come away
thinking hey you know maybe someday I'll
I'll consider making a female lead film
what I'm saying is whatever you're
working on right now everything that
you're working on right now boost the
female population and one of the
quickest ways in my opinion to reach
gender parity is to go through a script
that you're already going to make and
cross out a bunch of first names and of
ensemble characters and supporting
characters and make them female and with
one stroke you have created some non
stereotyped characters who might turn
out to be even more interesting now that
they've had a gender swap it's simple
and then cast me seriously seriously I
mean humanitarian yeah yes
but here's the thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm just is is there a reason it can't
also benefit me personally let's go so
here's my theory of change nearly every
sector of our society has a huge gender
disparity problem but there's one
category of gross gender inequality
where the under-representation of women
can be fixed
absolutely overnight on screen let's
make this change happen right now
tomorrow morning look at the projects
are working on and do a gender and
diversity pass don't make one more movie
without doing that first tape a sign
their office wall that says no more
missed opportunities let's do this okay
thank you very much
[Applause]